hello I'm Alison rich and today I'll be
talking with the birth of birth control
yeah
so Margaret Sanger was a woman who had
19 her mother died from complications
from pregnancies she had been pregnant
18 times no yes I've been pregnant 0
times and I'm stressed out just thinking
about her so Margaret moved to New York
and was like I'm gonna be a nurse for
low-income women in New York City and
one of the patients she observed was
this woman Sadie sacks
these acts was a woman who had had three
children and her doctor was like if you
have another kid you're gonna you know
die and like your husband should sleep
on the roof and she's like okay cool so
what's so funny
it's really hard but I'm committed so
couple moons later someone comes up to
Margaret and then like hey who's the up
T she died from a self-induced abortion
and Margaret's like what the this is
horrible
there has to be a better way there must
be something like a pill that you can
take that's as easy as an aspirin you
know that your doctor can prescribe to
you that could control birth so Margot
was like you know what it's helpful to
be a nurse but it's not helpful enough
so in 1916 Margot and her sister Ethel
Byrne founded the Brownsville clinic in
Brooklyn New York and in the first 10
days for 250 ladies showed up
Margaret's like hey here's pamphlets I
want every woman's you know god I loved
her birth I've been drinking vodka and
cranberry juice like a real college
freshman so it's only a matter of time
before the New York Police Department's
vice squad shows up and
yeah we're cutting this down ladies are
getting information about their how
their own bodies work we don't like it
Marga is like it doesn't even matter
that my message of birth control is
already out there she wasn't gonna get
stopped shouting you're not okay so
she's giving a speech at this woman's
suffrage event and she's like if we do
not have control over our bodies then we
have nothing people think of sex is this
like weird thing that we're not supposed
to talk about but sex is basic to the
human experience as eating and pooping
and those are two things that I love so
much if I get an email from you half the
time I'm on my toilet I love to take my
laptop into the bath
so this rich lady catherine mccormack
was like hey mark would say what's up I
would like to give you not only my time
but my dollar bills so she was like I'm
gonna drop the accent for a second you
know cuz it's exhausting I want to help
you open up a new clinic I'm gonna tell
people I'm going to Europe for fashion
reasons but but really it's 4:00 so she
goes to Europe and orchestrated this
insane
fashion spy mission so all these
diaphragms get sewn into dresses she
comes out to the US with a year's supply
words of diaphragms and we're real big
on birth control clinic we're calling it
the American birth control league which
by 1942 was called Planned Parenthood
huge it's huge and marbeth oh what a
victory but at the same time this isn't
good enough so for decades Margaret had
this vision of some kind of pill and
finally she seeks out Gregory Pincus who
was kicked out of Harvard for doing like
in vitro fertilization on rabbits and
he's like blue blue blue I'm in my
basement
and Berger say I need to help you know
you need to help me do the opposite of
what you're doing but for human women
and not animal wrap and she's like she's
me was 40 grand for you to figure this
out I think this is like you had me at
$40,000 it's the sound of music
reference baby you had me at hello the
classic sound of music where Maria
because you had me at a low and I was
yeah cool
so then in 1952 greg pincus is like did
you do try to invent this pale when he
comes across his old Harvard colleague
John Rock Greg Pegasus I can try to make
this pillow
and Don Roque was like here's a hot tip
use this little hormone called
progesterone it shuts down ovulation
meaning eggs aren't coming out because
is like that's what I'm talking about
and in 1957 boom they create the pill so
in the first year of 500,000 women get
the pill it was hugely successful and
then by 1960 it was officially on the
market as a form of contraception the
development of the birth control pill is
the single most important development in
women's liberation I mean we're like we
can go to college we can join the
workforce we can experience the sexual
revolution it's really important
I don't know women just you kind of have
to think that you're gonna be some
superhero who accomplishes your career
aspirations without any bumps along the
way and also pops out a couple of kids
on the way whereas men can you know sort
of they have more time and it feels
unfair that's true
pS Margaret Sanger was a eugenicist but
everybody's perfect Martin Luther King
jr. I had affairs
you